c'est la réouverture des grilles pour
julien après deux mois d'arrêt de
travail
comme beaucoup de commerces sa librairie
a dû fermer afin de respecter les règles
du confinement
une première étape en douceur qui
soulage le commerçant impatient de
renouer le lien social avec sa clientèle
et de moi et évidemment comme tout le
monde qu'on est confiné et ben voilà le
propre du commerce et d'avoir des
clients et d'échanger avec eux etc alors
d'autant plus andré rieu effectivement
on parle beaucoup de livres on parle
beaucoup d'idées et il ya des échanges
donc voilà c'est ça qui m'a manqué et je
suis vraiment impatient de revoir des
gens est ravi de pouvoir échanger avec
une réouverture qui ne se fait cependant
pas sans précaution l'ensemble des
commerçants ont en effet reçu ce matin
un kit de redémarrage fournis par la
commune attend de s'assurer de la
conformité des locaux a été offert par
un converti en 3d et puis des matches
que nous avons aussi récupéré travers va
perdre harper et que nous avons affecté
ailleurs dans la ville
ce salon de coiffure l'est son rideau
baissé pour le premier jour du
déconfinement ici on désinfecte et on
enlève la poussière accumulée après
presque deux mois d'inactivité et on
prépare l'accueil des clients attendre à
l'intérieur elles attendront à
l'extérieur elles ont l'obligation se
désinfecter l'hydraulique à l'entrée
ensuite elles seront installées ou la
placera désinfecter à chaque passage de
clients c'est la grande nouveauté chez
nous parce qu'elle habituellement
s'était fait quotidiennement mais pas à
chaque passage même son de cloche pour
cette boutique de prêt-à-porter ici le
magasin est divisé en deux espaces pas
plus de deux clients dans chacun des
mesures contraignantes mais nécessaire
dans ces commerces où les clients sont
amenés à toucher les produits
on a enlevé une cabine sur deux pour que
les distances à respecter également les
vêtements qui sont essayés seront mis en
quarantaine
pour quelques heures ou pour la nuit
c'était l'après midi et si jamais
devrait être essayée dans la foulée on a
aussi la machine à vapeur pour
désinfecter 60 dollars une reprise qui
comporte néanmoins quelques zones
d'ombré pour les commerçants le flou sur
le protocole sanitaire dont les
boutiques entraîne angoissent et
frustration à ceux des confinement